quality alright so this movie the
turning is horrifying but I want to know
what scares you guys um you can go first
yeah I have a fear of like we were
talking about it before like I'm not
scared of spiders alone but obviously I
think of spiders crawling on me I don't
like that yeah sometimes I get like
parents sometimes I'll have like a weird
like just like a piece of lint on my
shoulder and I'll think it's like
bullies but uh you know I don't know I I
have like I mean for a long time is a
dark period of dark or whatever but now
it's you know I'm fine with it yeah
totally fine with it
no night wait for me anymore I still
need a night like I have to in my room I
have a sound machine that has a light
coming out of it and then I have like
this like thing that has like a white
noise machine or something oh yeah
machine I like white noise because it
like distracts me from like all like the
sounds outside I'm scared of Pennywise
and scared like of the dark a lot I'm
scared of I'm scared of frogs yeah you
were telling me about that yeah it's
traumatizing because when I was 3 yeah
um I I went to go inside and a Frog
hopped on my shoe he kicked it inside
the house it was jumping all over the
house yeah she told me about that like
one of the first days I met her and I
was like that's your fears frogs she was
like yep and I was like hey yeah I gotta
work on my fears so you guys have joined
the creepy kids in horror films legacy
that's a thing oh thank you yeah shining
kids what the Hoss Hannah yeah why why
do kids scare us so much
phil's mmm I think we're we have a lot
of them like a lot of you know imagine
we have a lot of imagination yeah and we
bring that to life in a lot of movies
and also kids have like they're not into
the stage of maturity yet and um and I
feel like that's really creepy sometimes
to be like let's not no not ya know what
they're gonna do next
yeah and cuz guns aren't predictable
yeah kids are honestly unpredictable and
having that like just I think scares a
lot of people yeah yeah we see you
driving the ecto-1
oh and ghostbusters sure what the heck
do you get to wear the pack I don't know
see it might be I think it is yeah yeah
yeah I'm like is it a secret yeah no
yeah no I'm not actually gonna say he
didn't fix it but I know maybe I don't
know and are you allowed to watch this
film like will your parents like my mom
my mom and my dad will probably be okay
with it
if I was like wasn't scared of almost
everything like going to the bathroom by
myself at restaurants that is terrifying
I actually hit that time getting out of
bed at night cuz I feel like some things
are gonna reach out and grab my ankles
so like I just run as fast as I can and
like try to jump up and down so it they
can't miss me I'm scared of Airport
bathrooms because everyone's in there
everyone's just having a good time we're
in there together together yeah
I think when I'm like 13 15
18 I could watch it getting bigger yes
the numbers is getting bigger awesome
well thank you so much the film is
fantastic thank you yeah thanks so much
nice to meet you there's being here